welcome to this video playing veteran
Russ better in Russian we had this
earlier and I had a plate Amalia and I
was first thing it was wet arenas or
something and of course it's better in
Russian so we get the the Leningrad
Dutch
okay I will probably never understand
this opening you click put stuff on the
edge of the board and so on but it
oftentimes works out quite okay for
black
the porn tapes look strange and he plays
it immediately
of course I'm ships III Queen a4 looks
pretty awful okay
like eggs at least brings this piece
back into the game okay so what exactly
Bishop c3 what's going on here that
looks like it loses stuff now
Queen takes c6 I can win this it's all
right of course but this is probably the
easiest way yeah I can take this pawn
but I can also just continue to to
pressurize them I mean this is the
structure it's terrible
okay an H for this f1 so this is not
super easy
okay I'm going to give a bit more
protection here for the porn and
preventive war and so on
now how to do this in Crete c5 and then
clicking maybe or queen f1 then taking I
don't know the boat looks pretty strong
to do the difficult to judge here
because everything looks good but then
you still have to decide what to do
[Music]
should take c6 is not quite working it
is just maybe just this and rook b8
Queen trade is also pretty strong
maybe takes first and then we will be
able stronger ah I have it this is okay
I mean it's perfectly fine okay some p7
doesn't quite work that close so mb6 is
good or just this I drop the ADA it's
got really weird construction here
[Music]
check check this position looks so weak
in many ways that they lack a line
should should be something and this was
probably a little bit coincidental that
the pressure was so high on blacks
position I don't think you can hold it
and I could have taken material and all
the wave it I mean a Kia bishop c6 is
probably just a good move here play with
the pawn up we're just thinking okay
well they didn't want to sell this off
to cheap and I mean yeah it's like
trusting all the way here I should take
immediately in PlayBook p8 I saw it
right after I played it he has no move
here's the thing absolutely no move
yeah like here I take take take and
threaten this and here's Bishop b4 and
everything falls apart okay this is not
a huge difference
yeah Queen d6 didn't work but but where
do you go I mean it's the thing check
check yeah that can sometimes happen if
you play the dutch and then weaken
yourself so much sometimes so they're
just too many holes okay guys thanks for
watching